you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game four
from the 2014 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand going into this round both players
remain level at one and a half points
each and Carlsen with the white pieces
in this one he opened with e4 Anand
replying with the Sicilian defense we
don't have a very dynamic play in this
one I think it's more of a maneuvering
maneuvering type of game positional type
of game in this one Knight f3 e6
and now g3 preparing a king side fiend
keto knight c6 Bishop g2 black build the
center castles Knight f6 and something
needs to be done about this Pandu out d4
is it to strike at this and eventually
these guys will be exchanged and what do
you know we have this isolated D pawn
structure that is the main focus of the
game playing against the isolated deep
on following up we have Bishop e7 and
then al Bishop to e3 something I was
referencing during the livestream is
this idea instead of Bishop to e3 it
might be tempting on the white side to
take on c5 and then the land this check
but do know that this would be a
perfectly good reply to a check
sometimes there might be some fear of
blocking on the e6 square with the
bishop because of Knight g5 however do
know that black has very strong play
against this weakened f2 square it has
been weakened as soon as the rook played
to e1 if this rook does give a check in
the bishop blocks and the knight jumps
into attack black and simply castle this
is an open position development is most
important Black has all their pieces
working or is at least very close to
having all their pieces working the
Queen is the only one who needs to move
in order for black to become fully
developed if Knight takes pawn takes
rook takes these guys are doing nothing
and already we have sacrifices on f2
that are available for black okay we
have this idea where King takes Knight
e4 white is simply getting killed that's
double check Queen b6 you get the idea
white would be in a very difficult
position I just wanted to highlight that
in this position to take on c5 and then
try to jump in here and land this check
this is a convenient way to block the
check without fear of Knight g5 piling
up on that pinned piece in the game
white wanted to force black to capture
on d4 therefore was Bishop to e3
exerting more pressure on the c5 pawn
black takes the knight is there to
recapture not too many more exchanges in
this game not for awhile least from this
point on there won't be any exchanges
for a little bit a lot of maneuvering
getting pieces to good squares coming up
black develops now with tempo white is
there reacting with that move is also
looking to maybe jump into f5 black
interferes with that good idea also
Queen d7 is not allowing h3 to kick this
bishop this guy here can be a bit of a
pain to the white side watching out on
that d1 square square that the Queen
rook would one day like to make use of
which where can put additional pressure
on the d5 pawn but that's not so easily
accomplished getting in that h3 advanced
Queen d7 interferes with that and again
watches over the f5 square ID to castles
Knight f3 some nice harmony in the
position the Knights are connected these
Knights here
opposite one another are fighting for
the central dark squares they offset
rookie a rookie one small improvements
here Bishop to e5 this by the way this
moment here White has this option of
taking on c6 and then following up with
Knight e5 however there is the move
Queen b7 and if the knight is taking out
the light square Bishop Knight g4 Bishop
d4 there is now Bishop f6 exchanging one
of the bishops and this is a perfectly
fine position for black a reliable home
certainly for the f6 Knight and white is
still having to react to this threat on
the B pun pretty much equal position I
didn't have that was an interesting idea
though a forcing line something to
calculate without question to capture
and then follow up with the fork you are
after all picking up a valuable bishop
but I believe black would have been fine
in that line in the game we had rook e1
and Bishop d6 so now this idea certainly
ruled out all together both bishop at
night are now watching over e5 c3
reinforces the d4 point rules out any
Knight b4 ideas maybe in some cases that
could be a bit of a nuisance to the
Queen h6 black has a flight square queen
f1 this is a move during the livestream
that I was doing I thought it was a move
that took about a half hour
apparently I lost track of time it only
took about 10 minutes for Queen the f1
to be played and the idea behind it is
unless the clocks are messed up right
now but I'm not quite sure anyhow this
was the big think of the game right here
this moment move 15 took about 10
minutes judging by the clocks at least
right here Queen f1 is permitting now h3
to give this Bishop a kick announce
spent nearly 20 minutes on his reply why
did he take so much time well there is a
serious idea in mind with Queen f1 it's
not just to give the bishop a kick it's
to one day maybe force
a knight for Bishop exchange as an
example just making a passive move here
such as a six there can follow h3 if the
bishop retreats to one of these two of
course the knight can take him out and
if he tries to go elsewhere such as
Bishop h5 there is Knight h4 and g4 is
not long off forcing the bishop to g6
and then we can have again this night
for Bishop exchange is very important
imbalance in chess so in order to meet
this idea of h3 and trying to hunt the
Bishop down we have the voluntary excuse
me the voluntary retreat of the bishop
with the Bishop H v h3 Bishop g6 the
bishop gets on this diagonal before it's
maybe ruled out altogether now that the
bishop is no longer on this diagonal the
White Queen rook could finally play to
that d1 square there is no pin on this
diagonal now that the bishop is no
longer on that g4 or h5 square black
gets their rook involved all pieces
central the rooks opposite from one
another really well-placed pieces for
both sides black is there to reinforce
this isolated pawn and white is in a
position to maybe one day put pressure
on it we do see that take shape at this
moment here after Knight takes Knight
pawn takes c4 and things are starting to
open up a little bit pressure is
mounting against d5 the more exchanges
by the way on the white side the better
it's more likely that this isolated pawn
becomes a weakness with fewer pieces on
the board would be a more accessible
point Bishop efore is welcoming a light
square bishop exchange bishop d4 the
knight is hit Knight h7 another option
was rook to e6 preparing to recapture
with the rook or even double along the
e-file
but with night 2h7 there's ideas of one
day Knight g5 to put some pressure on
these light squares or as was pointed
out by Anand after the game this idea of
playing into f6 or excuse me f8 and then
circling back to e6 this is a nice post
a nice defensive post certainly for the
black King to have a night on f8 later
on he does take that route
he plays into f8 and e six as it turns
out is a very nice square following up
we have C takes D Bishop takes D the
pair of rooks are off and now the queen
is no longer needed on f1 she improves
her position this is what I was talking
about earlier this is a maneuvering type
of game a positional approach small
steady improvements there's no great
haymakers in the position no great
tactics just slow progress that's being
made here the Queen slowly improving
she's now functioning along this file if
Bishop takes a 2 there's already tactics
in the form of Bishop takes g7
unleashing the Queen and rook on that d6
Bishop Bishop - excuse me Knight to f8
at this point and now Knight to h4
welcoming a LightSquared bishop exchange
Bishop e5 this is a nice move taking
into account what exactly this Bishop on
d4 there's no way that blacks dark
square Bishop is better than White's
right here who is pointing right at the
heart of this structure on the Kings
side g7 so black looks to neutralize
this well-placed dark square bishop with
Bishop to e5 Bishop takes Bishop Queen
takes and the other bishops are off and
now this is a decision point for black
to keep the Queen's on the board or not
you could have this but at the end of it
the white rook is the one who's likely
to be more active than the black rook
could even have the knight jumping into
f3 rook d5
in this rook maybe doing something else
like coming over to a3 or even
exchanging this would be a great asset
in this ending I don't know that that
would be such a good option here after
Knight to f3 to even go into the d5
square maybe rook a five interesting
endgame white is the one who's still
trying for something having the better
pawn structure that was that is
essentially what it this ending is
coming down to is there some play
against the one liability in the
position the black Queen side pawn
structure these guys here being split
and isolated we didn't have that the
Queen's remained on board in this game
in fact they never left Bishop takes
Bishop Queen takes and now b3 ok just
meeting Queen takes B to the knight gets
into the nice square on e6 this pond
will be no issue for black to watch over
with this Knight on e6 if black needs
this pond to be defended he can always
bump up one Square and everything is
really well coordinated right the pawn
on f7 defends the night the night would
be defending the pawn on c5 the only
liability is maybe that a7 pond but he
could be defended I believe quite easily
with maybe a rook or a Recor Queen we
don't have any pressure being placed on
that pawn however in this game we have
Knight f3 Queen f6 so he's just getting
back into play Queen f6 backing up we
have this idea of maybe a rook jumping
into d8 King G to this pawn or excuse me
the knight on f3 was only being watched
over by the Queen so a little bit of a
change of the guard King g2 defends the
knight this is freeing up the Queen to
do other more exciting things such as
Queen a6 that would be a good way to put
pressure on these weak links following
up rook da Queen e2 and black is not so
quick to exchange
instead rook d5 basically saying if you
want a rook exchange you're going to
allow me to have a past pun and that's
what takes shape rook takes pawn takes
he's a runner but it's not so easy to
get him that's so easy to get him going
there is a knight in the queen that can
track him right down in fact the knight
an excellent block hater he could jump
into d3 and put a great halt to that pun
he could only go as far as d4 as long as
there's a knight around and that d3
square not so easily dislodged from this
post as a follow up it is 95 queen of
593 Knight d4 and now g4 this was a
sharp move Carlsen by the way is with
this last move just under six minutes
he's still needing to meet the 40th move
both players still needing to make their
40 moves in pretty pretty much limited
time here sharp move though g4 hitting
the Queen it's a counter punch black and
take this and we're going to get the
Queen right back we didn't have that
Queen d7 like I said the Queen's never
left this game if Knight takes Queen in
this position pawn takes and if let's
say Knight here well this problem will
be tracked right down Knight f4 Knight
takes Knight takes this is a bit
dangerous you know these guys can be
forced through with time they could be
come past but it should still be hold
abut certainly a lot of calculation
remains for as long as the Knights are
around we didn't have Knight takes Queen
but rather Queen d7 this is a nice
square for the black Queen coordinated
well with the pawns watching over the
past pawn and pawn on a7 these pawns
here are watched over by the King Queen
e5 improving the post of the Queen
hitting the night the night drops back
king g3 Queen b5 the knight is hit
Knight f4 the Knights come off the
Queen's are still on board King and pawn
ending width some pair of Queens on the
board how to make crop progress it's
very difficult both sides need to be
cautious of perpetual check white is the
one who is slightly better in this
position because of the better King
position and this pawn can maybe turn
out to be in fact a liability if there's
some way that the white queen can
establish a position where all the base
points are controlled there's maybe a
way to try and get that pawn but it's
very difficult to do the black Queen
remains in this game super active first
playing to be for pushing the pawn white
inserts a check and picks up f7 but
after Queen d2 again she remains very
active pressure on a2 there's ideas of
checks here maybe even a perpetual check
during the game someone had asked or
during the livestream someone had asked
about this move Queen takes a seven why
wasn't Queen takes a seven played here
in the game we saw Queen f5 but what
about Queen takes pawn what would happen
we can have Queen d3 on King G - there's
Queen e4 how do you avoid these checks
King G one Queen e1 King G to Queenie
four it's going to turn out to be
perpetual check suppose you try to do
something else after Queen takes on a7
suppose after check here the King goes I
don't know suppose he goes here Queen d2
King g3 and after Queen d3 suppose he
goes here to avoid checks
well now white has to be careful of not
just perpetual check but of losing I
don't care if these two pawns are passed
and connected look at how far away they
are from queening this guy by the way
the D pawn is just a few steps away
so if white is going in this direction
to avoid the perpetual check they're
also going in a direction where they're
not going to be around to stop this pond
from advancing the Queen is the only one
that would really be needed in order to
escort this pond down to the promotion
square so it's the short story I guess
is that if white at this moment is going
to pick up the pawn black is always in a
position to a give a perpetual check or
be in some in some cases here shoulder
off the king and try and promote their
own punt we didn't have Queen takes a
but rather Queen a5 check King h8 h for
the idea with this move is something
black has to attend to to get in g5 and
g6 if a pawn if a white pawn is
established on g6 there's all of a
sudden mating nets against the king pawn
here
guards f7 and h7 white at that point
would only be needing to throw a piece
on this back rank here and that would be
game over black is not going to allow
that to happen though grabbing the a
pawn ready to pick up another one with
check black Queen stays very active so
too does the white King but after Queen
d2 again she remains very active ideas
of Queen to d1 check Queen d3 if she's
getting into d1 there's checks over here
on g1 or h1 there's not really a great
way to make progress here if the King
tries to get active towards the center
this is in fact losing there go the
Queens and here comes a new one so you
can't just go towards this pawn so
easily again there are these checks with
Queen d1 Queen d3 always something to
constantly watch don't watch over the
Queen is restricted she has too many
things that she needs to do watch over
this pond
she cannot watch over this pond and
still facilitate this type of an advance
that's one of the ideas behind Queen
d - I should have mentioned that not
only Queen D 3 and Queen D 1 but she's
also stopping this idea of g 5 g 6 to
plant upon on that g 6 square looking
for mating ideas so after Queen D 2 this
was a very strong move and basically the
last move of the game because as it
follows up we do in fact have a draw
being agreed after Queenie a king h 7
queenie 4 check King h8 Queen 2 e 8
check King H 7 it is at this point that
the players agreed to a draw so this is
now the second draw the game but in both
games that were draws in games one and
in this game four they were without
question fighting draws and we are yet
again level in this map in this match
both players now having two points each
tomorrow as a rest day and game 5 will
pick up on November 14th and I will
continue to track the progress of this
match in live stream it and do videos of
each of the games and maybe you'll tune
in for some of them if you can so feel
free to share what your thoughts are on
this and I'll catch you in the next
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye
you
[Music]